I think collectively in the largest
sense i think that it is important to
figure out a kind of version of health
care delivery that is more like the rest
of the world and less like the way we do
it I think that's an important
collective thing to do I would say maybe
that's the single most important that
thing that we can do collectively
individually again I think I think
people need to see in their daily lives
to try to act correctly I mean in the
obvious ways that could mean turning off
your lives using a little ugly
fluorescent bulbs driving cars to get
better mileage and I don't want to
disparage any of those because I try to
do all those and those are good but I
mean just in acts with individuals of
not being niggardly and not being not
decembe leanness tanned and and I think
I mean it's like a parental exhortation
but I think once you get into the habit
of honesty and kindness on those
individual level with your co-workers
and your children and your spouse and
everybody else I think not only do those
billions of Acts add up into a better
society culture world but they also
train one for that time that may come
when you're asked to do the right thing
in a big character defining way you're
more inclined to do it if along the way
you've you've you've done the right
thing and all these small boring but
niall daily ways